okay good morning everybody my name is
Michael Kelleher I'm the program
director of The Donald Windham and sandy
m campbell literature prizes here at
Yale University on behalf of the
director of the by Nicki and Rare Book
and Manuscript library who was unable to
attend this morning I'd like to welcome
all of you to this historic announcement
when he left his estate to Yale in 2010
Donald Windham made very few demands
other than that the awards be made
annually in amounts deficient to provide
the recipient with the resources to
pursue his or her writing for a year
without having to be concerned with
outside support the only requirement is
that recipients accept the award in
person and participate in a campus
literary festival which is scheduled to
take place from sep tember 10 to 13
Windham and Campbell's generosity and
love of great writing are evident in the
global scale of the awards prizes are
available to english-language writers at
all stages of their careers from
anywhere in the world provided they have
one published book or one professionally
produced play to their credit this year
there were 59 nominees from 10 countries
representing through the excellence of
their writing the breadth and depth of
english-language literature from around
the world for mr. Wyndham swishes we
also solicited nominations for writers
of promise writers whose work deserves a
wider audience and writers whose sole
means of support as they're writing
today's recipients did not know they
were nominated and they were not aware
that their nominations progressed
through a year-long process that
involved 29 nominators three panels of
jurors an eight-member selection
committee all of whom agreed to work in
the strictest confidentiality I'd like
to thank those 46 anonymous individuals
for sharing their expertise and for
producing an outstanding inaugural list
of prize winners give them
starting a prize of this magnitude
requires the hard work in support of
many the estate of Donald Windham the
office of the university president the
office of development the director and
staff of the by Nicki and the prize
steering committee each deserve thanks
for working to develop and implement a
process that is as rigorous as it is
fair as focused on excellence as it is
global in reach and with that I'd like
to introduce president-elect Peter
salafi who will read the winners of the
first Windham Campbell prizes thank you
very much Michael thank you all for
being here today for essentially a
historic announcement since this is the
first Windham Campbell Prize
announcement and I'm delighted to be
here for this historical occasion as
well so yell is a place that hopes to
inspire and recognize greatness in every
field and the wyndham Campbell prizes
allow us to fulfill that ambition in the
field of world literature in ways we are
only beginning to understand i'm
particularly looking forward to our
prize winners joining us for the
literary festival in September the
festival will be a boon to the
intellectual and educational mission of
the University and as Michael said we're
deeply indebted to Donald Windham and
Sandy Campbell for creating this legacy
this is a global writers prize which
supports writers at all stages of their
careers in the practice of their craft
the individuals that we recognize today
are inspiring to us as artists of the
first order and it is truly excited to
provide these authors with the means to
develop their work in ways that will
benefit all of us who love to read so I
look forward to the dialogue these
winners will inspire on the el campus
and around the world especially when
they come here this fall are we ready
the winners of the window campbell
prizes for fiction are awarded to james
salter Tom McCarthy and Zoe Wickham for
nonfiction the winners are Adina Hoffman
Johnny Steinberg and Jeremy scale for
drama the winners are nami wallace
stephen adly girgis and Tarell Alvin
McCraney why don't we pause for a minute
and congratulate all of them and we
thank all of these winners for the ways
of which their work has enriched all of
us we congratulate them on this
incredible achievement and all look
forward to interacting with them in
September so thank you all once again
for being here and thank you Michael for
all the work in shepherding this first
set of Wyndham Campbell Prize winners
thanks very much
so I'll be happy to take any questions
that anybody would like to offer about
the prizes the selection process it's in
the back well we figured the globe was a
large enough Geographic space to cover
to try to also include other languages
would would make it an even larger task
than it already is so some of it had to
do with practical concerns but I think
some of it also had to do with the fact
that we felt that trying to find people
who could actually read in all these
other languages to do these judges would
really make it difficult to provide the
kind of excellence that we think we can
provide in English well I like to say
that in the aggregate this year we are
giving out more than the nobel prize for
literature so yeah it's pretty big yes
I think it was they wanted to from what
I could from what I've read in the
agreements I wasn't party to the actual
discussion that established that amount
but from what I could see it was Donald
Windham swish that we give out enough
prizes that were supporting a lot of
writers but maybe not so many that we
are diluting the prestige of the award
and so based on the amount of interest
that the fund was going to earn they
divided up by a certain amount of prizes
that they thought was sufficient and
came up with 150 yes this this will be
an annual prize and there will be nine
prizes available every year I would say
it's pretty definite we're going to add
poetry in a couple of years I think we
wanted to get it off the ground first
and you may know that Yale already has
two very prestigious poetry prize as the
Bolling in prizes which is also
administered by the by Nikki library as
well as the Yale younger poets prize and
so that we wanted to make sure that when
we add poetry that we do so in a way
that enhances those prizes rather than
than taking away from them so yes
we we had 29 nominators and we asked
each nominator to make two nominations
and the two nominations were based on
two separate criteria the first was for
the author of a body of significant work
that has had a broad impact or deserves
a wider audience and the second was for
the author of work that has exhibited
outstanding promise and we asked them
specifically to make sure to nominate
under each of those categories because
it was Windham zyk split wish that we
recognize emerging writers as a part of
this prize and support them in the
practice there are in the development of
their art yes that's correct it just
happened that way we just happen to have
a great writer Adina Hoffman who
actually is with us today if any of the
press would like to talk to her if you
may want to stand up
and and that's that's really how it
happened and anybody else yes I made the
Queen we made the selections on
Wednesday that we had at the selection
committee came to town and we met all
day long and we had so thursday morning
I started calling all of the
prizewinners actually one of them jeremy
scahill i called that night because we
happen to be emailing each other at
twelve thirty in the morning and so I
made I made the call to him at about
twelve-thirty and and he said he had to
get up his mother was visiting him in
Brooklyn and he had to go wake her up to
make sure that it was real and the next
day I spent the better part of the
morning calling the prizewinners and
letting them know that they had won the
prize and I have to say it was a really
profoundly moving experience that people
were as you can imagine utterly shocked
none of them knew they were nominated
for the prize and and and some of them
really felt emotional and and expressed
that in in their remarks to me and you
can actually in if you have a press kit
with their available at the door there
there are other remarks that they made
are listed as well so anybody else
alright well thank you this has been a
really gratifying year for me and for
everybody that's been involved in
developing this prize and we're really
happy to have you all here once again
thank you to president-elect Sal of a
and congratulations to all our winners
and please join us for a reception
across the bay
you